first the golden knights have been hit
by covet 19.
let's get right over to sports director
chris matthews for more on this
developing story tonight chris
yeah thank you denise this breaking
story this evening the team announcing
four players have tested positive for
the virus the knights released in a
statement saying
four golden knights players recently
tested positive for the covid virus
those players have been self-isolating
and are
all recovering well as a precautionary
measure
the statement goes on to say the golden
knights off-ice player areas will be
closed
to all players and team staff through
the thanksgiving holiday
weekend now according to the knights
those players are self-isolating and so
they were not part of
today's food drive where members of the
knights and coaching staff
were handing out turkeys other canned
goods and groceries
as a community service event once again
we want to make this clear
all the nights players and coaches at
today's food drive were cleared
to be there city national hockey
programming the arsenal mckenzie river
pizza will remain
open at city national and will continue
to operate under the guidelines
set forth by the state of nevada and
local health officials the knights
telling us they will continue to follow
recommendations and guidance
from the cdc nhl and our local officials
to ensure health and safety of our
community players
and staff even the best efforts nobody
appears immune